nous faisons partie de l'opération siège
de la capitale mais nous sommes loin de
la
capitale donc décision a été prise pour
qu'on nous écoute un petit peu plus de
se rapprocher de la
capitale bravo
chef 24 heur après le blocage de la 13
sur le péage de bûchelet les
agriculteurs ont décidé de durcir le
mouvement d'après nos informations et
d'après l'assemblée générale qui s'est
tenu juste à l'instant avec les
agriculteurs yvelinois et du département
de l'UR les agriculteurs ont décidé de
s'avancer vers Paris direction le
triangle de rquencour une décision qui
fait suite et bien au discours de
politique générale du Premier ministre
cet après-midi Gabriel Atal a fait
plusieurs annonces concernant les
agriculteurs mais il semblerait que
c'est soit insuffisant aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit qu'on n'est pas vraiment
écouté euh euh on a à peine parlé de
nous enfin au niveau de du gouvernement
là je vois un panneau au-dessus où il y
a marqué Porte Maillot plus 13 minutes
donc en
fait aujourd'hui si on embête pas les
gens notre métier c'est pas d'embêter
les gens mais si on les embête pas on
n'est pas écouté on n'est pas pris au
sérieux donc on a voulu faire de la
communication en se mettant ici sans
embêter les gens ou un minimum et
aujourd'hui on n pas écouté donc et ben
on avance vers la capitale c'est
l'opération c'est siège de la capitale
on avance vers la
capitale et vous le voyez derrière moi
les agriculteurs commencent à
s'organiser pour déménager et bien de
bûchelet parce qu'ils s'étaient très
bien organisé ils avaient notamment mis
en place des tables plusieurs barbecue
il y a même un foot truck où il pouvaent
s'alimenter il y a des dortoirs aussi
pour dormir bref ils avaient installé un
véritable campement ici à bûchelet et
bien là c'est l'heure de tout ranger et
de reprendre les tracteurs pour prendre
la direction de roc encour départ prévu
aux environs de 19h30